For my part I think the most important
thing about hiring early on or
at any point your startup but
especially early on is the same thing
that's important wiuth everything you do
as an entrepreneur, and I suspect it.
And that's to sort of to trust your
instincts and trust your judgment.
It's good to think about these things.
It's good to read about
other people's experiences.
It's good to listen to me and
what I went through, but
the most important thing, when I've
gone wrong hiring, when I've gone wrong
with product plans and launches,
it's because I didn't trust myself.
I don't listen to myself.
If you feel like it's
a good hire go after it.
If you don't, don't.
But the most important thing is to
trust yourself as an entrepreneur.